The joe rogan experience.
I don't know.
I think Obama is about to give a
speech today about this nonsense.
Yeah,
the,
even CNN,
the front of it is like Obama's
challenge convincing you on Syria.
It's 0% of the public
thinks we should do it.
I haven't seen one person argue
that we should attack Syria.
Literally my mom even said she didn't
want to go to war and she was always
backing up all the other words.
I think people are just learning.
It's just we've been hoarse,
fucked for so many years now.
We've been horse fuck since 2001 I
mean that's really hard to believe.
It's really hard to believe that it's
been 12 years of horse fucking the whole
world's been horse fucked
and at this point time,
especially with this second term of this
supposedly liberal and ordering drone
strikes like crazy threatening
military action for this one.
Ambiguous.
I mean,
I don't know who the
fuck cause that strike,
but I know Ron Paul says that
it was a false flag is Ron Paul,
right?
What the fuck do I know?
But if somebody wanted us to go to Syria
for some other reason and they decided
to orchestrate and attack,
that would force the United States
hand and to going into Syria.
Shit,
dude,
that's possible.
If you don't pay attention to history,
you might think it's not possible.
But if you do pay attention to history,
it's,
it's happened.
It happened with the Gulf
of Tonkin [inaudible] it,
and that was even Shaker.
There was even faker than this.
Well,
look from the Pov of,
uh,
some,
some are revolutionary
fundamentalist Islamic,
uh,
person who's planning these attacks.
We know that,
uh,
a lot of people,
people who are fundamentalist Islamic,
wha what we call terrorists,
they don't have a problem putting dynamite
in their body and blowing themselves
up.
So it's not beyond the Pale to
think that in the scheme of things,
once they realize if
they do a serin attack,
it could possibly cause the United States
to attack and unleash hell on Assad.
Well,
yeah,
that's a logical decision to make.
And why would a sod knowing that
if he did a chemical attack,
it could cause the,
all the gains he's made in his shitty
Goddamn a civil war to go away.
Why would he do that?
Doesn't make any sense and easy.
I don't,
he seems,
I think he's a vicious piece
of shit from what I've read,
but he doesn't seem stupid.
And apparently he was already kind of
winning that war as are making great
advances,
you know,
so I don't know why suddenly he's like,
yeah,
I released the gas,
the gas that will make it so that we
get in a super power to stop bump,
start bombing us.
And who was he fighting against?
Isn't he fighting against the Taliban?
Uh,
well it's a may fight against al Qaeda.
It's not just al Qaeda.
It's a mixture.
From what I saw,
there was this,
uh,
I can't remember,
it was on,
it wasn't on scene and it was on
one of these weird news channels.
It was just a conference with a Po
analysts talking about what Syria,
what the revolution or the
civil wars comprised of.
And it's not all al Qaeda.
And it's not all Taliban and it's not all,
it's different.
It's different groups.
Just in the same way,
if there was a revolution
in the United States,
it wouldn't just be one group.
It wouldn't just be the tea party,
right.
It would be an arc is,
it would be,
uh,
you occupy wall streeters.
It would be environmental is,
it would be fundamentalist Christians.
That's what a civil war really is,
is just this shattering of people into
groups with one initial main goal,
which is get Assad out of
power and then the next,
that's where revolution can really suck
or a civil work and really suck because
then the thing collapses on itself and
they all start attacking each other.
Did you see that John Kerry used
a fake photo to fuels Syrian war?
I heard him as the photo of the bodies.
This is the photo.
It's a photo from 2003 from the Iraq
war of a little boy jumping over these
lines of bodies and he
used that in a speech.
I'll try to beat the war drums.
How the fuck could he know
or how could he not know,
rather that that's a bad photo to use.
Yeah,
no shit,
man.
Of course he knew,
right?
How about McCain playing
fucking video poker?
Yeah.
When they were talking about box,
these are fucking sucks,
man.
They're,
they're talking about evaporating human
beings and the guys so comfortable.
These fucking playing video poker.
The only thing that he
thinks we should go,
doesn't he?
He was,
yeah.
He loves war McCain's a big,
he's a big fan of war.
He think he's supporting it,
right?
He supported like seven wards.
Yeah.
Oh hell yeah.
Here he comes.
This is the live.
Yeah.
Look at him.
He has to walk down a red
carpet and how dramatic
my fellow Americans.
Hello President.
No,
I don't want to talk to you about Syria.
Oh boy.
Why it matters and where we go from here.
Over the past two years,
what began as a series of peaceful
protests against the repressive regime of
Bashar al Assad has turned
into a brutal civil war.
Over a hundred thousand
people had been killed.
Millions have fled the
country in that time.
America's worked with allies to provide
humanitarian support to help the
moderate opposition and to
shape a political settlement,
but I have resisted calls for military
action because we cannot resolve someone
else's civil war through force,
particularly after a decade of
war in Iraq and Afghanistan.
The situation profoundly changed though
on August 21st when Assad's government
gassed to death over a thousand people,
including hundreds of children.
The images from this
massacre are sickening.
Men,
women,
children,
lying and rose killed my poison gas.
Others foaming at the mouth,
gasping for breath,
father clutching his bed,
show him on man,
imploring them to get up and walk.
It's better to set them on fire
and gruesome detail.
The of my nature of chemical weapons.
How crazy.
The same,
giving these images a father clutching
children like what do you do?
Are you,
what are you an actor?
Like what's with the dramatic narrative
of father clutching his children?
Babies could be your baby.
American Gis work on the many thousands
killed by deadly gas and the trenches of
Europe
in World War II.
The Nazis used gassed and flicked
the horror of the Holocaust.
We must use fire or not gas fire.
These weapons can kill on a mass scale.
What the distinction between
soldier and mass chill?
No distinction between soldier and fn
central like drones don't mean like
drones.
What about Hiroshima Teen 97
what about the 98% civilian rate?
Your drones have killed international
agreement prohibiting the use of chemical
weapons.
We sat him on five joints,
marinade on governments
national agreement that we shouldn't use
drones because I would think that that
would be a bad thing to use to.
These basic rules were violated.
Oh Man.
Pong with our sense of
common humanity of murder.
No one disputes that chemical
weapons were used in Syria.
The world saw thousands of videos,
cell phone pictures,
and social media accounts from the attack
and humanitarian organizations told
stories of hospitals packed with
people who had symptoms of poison gas.
Moreover,
we know the Assad regime was responsible
in the days leading up to August 21st
we know that Assad's chemical weapons
personnel prepared for an attack near an
area where they mix serin gas.
Could you imagine they distributed
gas mess to their trial?
Paranoid.
This dude gets it and they fired
rockets from a regime controlled areas.
He's killed tap dance on it.
She had all the kids,
not,
that's just one part of it.
But just imagine all the
conflict that he's engaged in.
Mortal death,
con wounded all over the globe.
You know,
seeing your figures.
It's really gross,
man.
If you have to like work on your speech
to tell people to go to war and kill it,
you don't want to hear what he says.
I don't hear it that shit.
But he said,
do you want to keep going?
Okay,
I just want to know if,
what if we're going to start bombing?
He's going,
we're start bombing.
He's gonna start doing something.
I think he might say,
we're going to cut.
I don't know.
Maybe you're right.
Listen to what he's saying.
There's commit atrocities.
They depend upon the world to look the
other way and until those horrifying
pictures fade from memory,
what about us,
man,
but these things happen.
We burn,
we did.
The facts cannot be denied.
The question now is what the United
States of America and the international
community is prepared to do about it?
Oh,
you mean France and Saudi Arabia's?
What happened to those people?
For those children?
There's not only a violation
of international law,
it's also a danger to our security.
Well,
let's call it the bombs
he's going to drop,
aren't going to kill them.
Explain why they don't kill any kids.
Two magnets going together to stop using
tells innocence baby bonds as the ban
against these weapons roads.
Other tyrants will have no reason to
think about acquiring poison gas and using
them.
Cheese over time were troops would
again face the prospect theory.
I'm going to get some poison gas.
It could be easier if the
terrorist organizations to
obtain this one gets a free
fucking liberal policy fighting
spills beyond sooner as well.
I knew poison gas pistol,
that is how someone who was a tea party,
Manchurian candidate would
react if they have blood.
You know,
Bama wants to be such a fucking pussy.
I had tissues,
country lesson on my own because none
of those terrorists have the balls to
fucking go after Americans
to keep America strong.
I went after America,
keep America strong,
dude.
I can't listen to it,
man.
I'm sure that Shit's going to take a long
ass time and then it's going to freak
everybody out and it's going to be
the subject of discussion tomorrow.
Um,
I think it's very unfortunate that we
live in this world and to listen to that,
to,
to think that he could be so free in
talking about this sort of moralization,
is that a word of warfare when
we've killed so many fucking people,
it's just really hard to believe.
And those numbers that
we read off about deaths,
those are just drones.
That's just drone deaths.
The 98% is just drone desks.
It doesn't even factor in how many
innocent people were killed in the wars in
Afghanistan and Iraq.
But yeah,
and again,
yeah,
it is the hypocrisy that it's
okay to kill people with fire.
It's not okay to kill with gas.
And this being s coming out of the mouth
of a man who regularly kills people
with fire.
Have you seen the video of the guys,
the rebels in the street
and get hit by a missile?
Now pull that shit up,
Brian.
The,
the,
they start screaming.
A lot of walk,
blah,
blah.
Walk Fire Gas,
which is search for madness.
Um,
how about Syrian rebels?
Hit with a bomb.
Maybe.
Let's say Syrian rebels.
Yup.
With bomb.
Okay.
Let me find out.
It's fucking madness.
It's a video.
Let's see.
Yeah.
Syrian rebels.
MMM HM.
People are all listening
to this speech right now,
man.
We should just be with Syrian rebels.
Almost hit by a bomb.
Let them listen,
man.
This,
uh,
this is being recorded.
It will be gone forever.
No,
that's not it.
There's one is one recent,
one of these guys in this
street and this bomb.
That's not it.
Our troops are coming
home from Afghanistan,
Afghanistan here.
The Americans want all
of us in Washington,
especially me to concentrate on the task
of building our nation here at home.
But I have to kill people back to work,
educating our kids.
Oh,
our kids,
owl,
God man's blood.
Molnlycke Molnlycke demand sacrifice.
Don't feed the owl God.
He comes to me and my dreams and if
I don't participate in the sacrifice,
I won't get the mansion.
They have reserved a mansion
for me on a hundred acres.
I will constantly have.
Okay.
Yeah.
This is the one thrown of diamonds.
The one of diamonds.
Wait for me at the end
of the black tunnel.
I must feed the our God.
Yeah.
What the fuck man?
Really?
Is that what we've come?
Yeah.
That is it,
man.
Now what now?
Hmm.
The beach.
The Lord desires blood.
If you've is so beautiful as words,
how do you spell [inaudible]?
Uh,
let me look at my tattoo.
It was worth 90% of your butthole joke.
Rabo you just,
you just,
you just gave me great ground.
I can't find this fucking thing.
These guys yell,
members of Congress have said there's no
point in simply doing a pinprick strike
pinprick.
Oh nope.
I never end up in one of its main breaks
strikes the United States military
doesn't do pinpricks.
We're just going to go down there
and pinch be even a limited stroke.
No other nation can deliver
and no other I talked about.
We shouldn't move another dictator with
force and we learned from a rock the
doing.
So it makes us responsible
for all that comes next.
But a targeted strike can make Assad or
any other dictator think twice before
using chemical weapons.
Dictators are thinking about
using chemical weapons right now.
Other questions involve the
dangerous or retaliation.
We don't dismiss any threats,
but the Assad regime does not have the
ability to seriously threatened our
military and the other.
Any other retaliation they might seek
is wine with threats that we face every
day.
So we're basically saying they're wheeler
Assad nor his allies have any interest
in escalation that would lead
to his demise and our ally.
Israel can defend itself
with overwhelming force.
We just want to kill this guy shakable
I'm conscious guy in the face of the
United States of America.
Yeah.
What is,
what the fuck is that many
of you have asked about?
Well,
should we get involved at all in a place
that's so complicated and where there's
one person wrote to me,
those who come after Assad may
be enemies of human rights.
You can write to Obama.
It's true that some of
us odds are extremists.
He'll listen,
he'll change it.
I'll cut up,
will only draw strength
in a more chaotic Syria.
If people there see the world doing
nothing to prevent innocent civilians from
being gassed to death,
we burned them.
We don't guess the majority of the Syrian
people and the Syrian opposition we
work with just want to live in peace
and freedom and the day
after any military action,
we would redouble our efforts to achieve
a political solution that strengthens
those who reject the forces
of tyranny and extremism.
Joe Biden beat me a poker.
He used to run Raytheon.
They sell how it Hellfire missiles,
but I mean,
listen to what he said.
What we're trying to stomp out
is exactly what we're doing.
I mean the,
the,
the massive amount of hypocrisy.
We should not be the world's policemen.
We should be the world's dragon.
And I have a deeply held
preference for peaceful solutions.
Pull up this video.
Syrian soldiers,
my administration,
Syrian rebels
by street crossing.
Well,
oh wait a minute.
That's not the one
I'm trying to find the right one.
Oh,
here it is.
Oh Damn.
It doesn't have a,
it has a crazy Arab name to it.
This wasn't him poke.
The Russian ghost is the
video willingness to join.
If you could find it in pushing aside
to give up his chemical water video.
The Assad regime has now admitted geyser,
uh,
weapons shooting in the street
and they get jack by a muscle.
This is what they're dealing with.
You got these guys who
have guns and like Duh,
Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh Duh.
They pull up in a pickup truck.
Wow.
And then like we have an even
bigger gun in the pickup truck.
They're going to kick some ass and uh hmm.
Watch all the shit hits the fan here,
man.
Siding,
siding day.
Everyone's about to half.
These are,
uh,
who's side are we on here?
I guess we're on the side of the
guys who are about to get jacked.
I who knows?
So they back.
The guy backs up his truck.
Okay.
And they don't even have
a chance to respond.
What?
Wash,
look at this.
They're trying to move Christ
uhmm and the guy's just screaming.
Allah Akbar.
Allahu Akbar.
Watch that again.
Back that up again.
Uh,
you're actually controlling it.
Oh,
sorry.
Can I do that?
I don't want to go to
another fucking war man.
One more time.
We did a good job of
filling the screen there,
buddy.
Yeah,
that's actually really good.
All right.
Watch this one more time.
Look,
they sort of realize it's happening.
Like look at them,
their body language like,
like they're like,
oh shit.
Oh Shit.
Okay.
Watch that stair you out the running.
Boom.
Are you fucking kidding me?
That's an ethical way to blow people up.
It's way better than chemical.
It's a beautiful thing.
Those guys are lucky.
That was like being killed
by an American Eagle.
That's like getting
killed by gourmet chef.
Couple sprints.
So precision.
The United States doesn't do
American pimp for seven decades.
I have a seven.
Let's here.
He's about to wrap it up.
Doing more than 40 zero
international agreements.
It has meant enforcing them.
The burdens of leadership are often heavy.
I can't get it up unless I'm
Caroline because we have born them.
And so to my friends on the right,
I ask you to reconcile your,
to America's
military might with a failure to
act when a cause is so plainly just,
okay,
let's stop.
So he's probably though is he's the CEO.
Is he the worst president we've ever had?
He's the most disappointing
for sure because Bush was
scary from the jump and he
was scary when he was going to war.
And it was scary when he
was misspelling words.
He was always scary.
But Obama was promising and now he's,
he's terrible.
That was awful.
And it was so corny.
It was so,
it was like watching that show.
What was that old a show
that used to be on Jag?
Remember Jag was a military
show on like NBC or CBS,
CBS,
CBS.
It was like,
you know,
it was fucking real clear.
The good guys.
Bad guys.
Good guys.
Always one.
Everything was,
it was an episode of Walker,
Texas Ranger.
That's what that was,
but he would just gave us,
I love what I really love is they try
to give the illusion that there's such
thing as a safe war.
That's what's really funny.
He's like,
I'm just going to stick this
stick and the Hornet's nest.
The Hornets can't fly over here.
You're going to be fine.
There'll be no retaliation.
They can't even retaliate and it's no
need to worry and it's the same kind of
retaliation.
That's true,
but how crazy is that?
How the,
the idea that you could just retaliate
and you could do that and not,
not face retaliation feet.
What if we attack Syria and
Russia decides to put missiles,
shields up.
Now what does out now we have Obama
leading us in a fucking world war three
against that crocodile Putin.
That's scary.
That's scary to think about,
man.
I don't know man.
I just,
I'm so disappointed in the whole way
this is laid out or the whole way this is
taking place.
Don't do that.
Probably we're going to get flagged
flagged for changing its color.
Yeah.
We get flagged terrorist activities.
When you're looking at 10 lag,
Darwin,
we're not doing anything wrong.
God Damn it.
I pay my taxes and
protest against war.
I can't believe you support a man who
would use chemicals to kill children.
Good Polo.
Let's smoke them out in that
funny you support the other guy.
If you don't think that
you should fire missiles,
oh,
now he's leaving.
The same way came in.
Oh my God.
Nice and dramatic that just that alone.
All of this ready attrical
shit was orchestrated.
Folks,
I guarantee you there are some
people that are involved in this.
There's some producers.
There's some,
there's an artistic director they want.
That was a,
that was a well planned out scene.
He walks up,
he walks back.
The fact that they do it in this ancient
stupid house where supposedly lives.
Meanwhile,
you know he's in some fucking seven mile
thick bunker down deep into the ground.
The bowels of the Earth were Dick Cheney
was hiding all throughout the Iraq war.
Remember,
here's just a metal slide.
He jumps in the shoot,
like a laundry chute,
jumps in and slides through the lens and
the towels and just go some cell phone
off and surrounded by lizards
who are like excellent work.
Yeah,
it's Batman's layer.
It's about got Batman's layer or anything
[inaudible]
oh shit.
Itunes or recording to
server the fuck outta here.
Server.